DEBI CABRERA:
Today we're talking
about Explainable AI, an
easier way to find products,
and a biopharma
breakthrough powered by AI.
I'm Debi Cabrera, and welcome
to "This Week in Cloud," where
we serve you the
lowest-latency news.
Explainable AI,
or XAI, helps you
understand and interpret how
your machine learning models
make decisions.
We're excited to announce that
BigQuery Explainable AI is now
generally available.
BigQuery is the
data warehouse that
supports Explainable AI in
the most comprehensive way
with regards to both XAI
methodology and model types,
all done at BigQuery
scale, enabling
millions of explanations within
seconds with a single SQL
query.
We created a new
All Products Page
to help you easily navigate
to your favorite Google Cloud
products.
This page showcases all of
the Google Cloud products,
as well as our key
partner products
in one easy-to-navigate place.
With one click, you can
discover the product that
is right for your solution.
We're proud to announce another
deep integration between Google
Cloud and Alphabet's AI research
organizations, the ability
in Vertex AI to run DeepMind's
groundbreaking protein
structure prediction
system, AlphaFold.
This is exciting news
for us, but game-changing
for data scientists and
organizations of all types
in the biopharma space, from
those developing treatments
for diseases to those creating
new synthetic biomaterials.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.